le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais le quartier du
bas de la rivière à saint denis est un
quartier chargés d'histoire la vocation
industrielle très précoce de ce dernier
en a fait le premier quartier industriel
de la ville de saint denis dans les
années 1700 il a donc participé
activement au développement du chef lieu
de la réunion
la rivière était détournée vers un canal
le canal des moulins pour faire tourner
paix ou la moudre le blé
au fil du temps l'équipement industriel
du quartier se complète avec
l'installation d'une tannerie d'une
usine de transformation de l'aloès d'un
abattoir à l'embouchure d'une fécule riz
d'une distillerie d'une chocolaterie et
d'une fabrique à tabac dans les années
20 mais l'urbanisation intensive du
quartier a complètement dénaturé cet
endroit pourtant authentique
alors comment faire renaître ce quartier
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
le jardin de l'état autrefois appelé
jardin du roi n'était pas là où il se
trouve aujourd'hui
jadis le jardin du roy était implanté
sur une parcelle de la rive droite de la
rivière simplement à la place de
l'ancien collège reydellet dans le
quartier du bas de la rivière
c'est pour cette raison que dans cette
ancienne cour d'école se trouve le seul
arbre à date de lille après la
construction du nouveau collège du
quartier
cet endroit est resté à l'abandon en
attente de destruction pour y faire
pousser des immeubles mais la présidente
du conseil général nassimah dindar a
souhaité faire renaître cet endroit en
un lieu innovant le conseil général soit
faire de ce quartier ain écoquartier
modèle servant d'expérimentation pour
d'autres quartiers et d'autres communes
c'est dans ce cadre qu'a été décidée la
rénovation de l'ancien collège la
renaissance de cet endroit chargé
d'histoire a intéressé les anciens
élèves et professeurs un mouvement
social s'est greffée au taux de ce
renouvellement
les anciens élèves et professeurs se
sont mobilisés et retrouvé grâce à
l'association les anciens du collège
rabelais on a été agréablement surpris
parce qu'on pensait pas qu'ils allaient
faire quelque chose d'aussi beau 2-6 2-6
respectueux de la nature dossiers
écologiques et on a été très content
parce qu'on n'y a été invité et intégrée
sans même en faire la demande
ils sont venus nous voir ils nous ont
proposé de participer à la vie de cet
espace et on est vraiment content voilà
il participé alors moi je suis moi même
une ancienne de jules reydellet j'ai je
suis né au bas de la rivière j'ai grandi
au bas de la rivière je suis partie
d'ailleurs il ya que quelques mois et il
ya quelques années j'ai voulu créer le
le groupe facebook pour retrouver mes
amis et je pense et curé que qu'une
dizaine de personnes dans ma classe et
quelques années après on est à plus de
mille deux cent mille deux cents
adhérents de toutes les générations
confondues des années 70 jusqu'à
maintenant et c'est en se réunissant
lors de divers soirée avec monsieur
moreau et d'autres élèves qu'on a eu
l'idée de créer l'association pour
pouvoir se réunir dans de bonnes
conditions alors le but de cette
association donc c'est de réunir les
anciens élèves de créer des activités de
faire des soirées où on se réunit des
soirées d'anciens élèves
mais c'est aussi le but de faire revivre
par l'esprit du collège on a des
milliers de photos et de vidéos des
années 70 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc ce qu'on aimerait bien faire donc
c'est de se retrouver autour de
l'exposition photos de soirée
retrouvailles et voilà pour se retrouver
et faire perdurer aussi l'esprit du
collège
j'ai travaillé pendant 30 ans dans ce
collège et pendant 30 ans j'ai vu des
générations d'élèves qui se sont succédé
ici et j'ai gardé contact avec je dis
pas toutes ces générations mais une
grande quantité de ces élèves que je
revois régulièrement qu'ils reviennent
me voir ils sont peu partout dans le
monde moi journée qui sont en australie
en nouvelle calédonie en guadeloupe etc
on garde contact par l'intermédiaire
d'un réseau social et ce qui est curieux
c'est qu'ils ont tous gardé un très bon
souvenir ce collège et le fait que ce
collège soit réhabilité pourrait aussi
c'est quelque chose de d'inestimables
effectivement là c'est là j'ai compris -
l'intérêt d'un réseau social et je crois
que pour ceux qui n'y sont pas encore à
les y est ça s'appelle les anciens du
collège reydellet allez-y vous allez
voir vous allez trouver des photos des
films et vous allez surtout vous
retrouver en vous inscrivant sur le site
vous allez retrouver vos anciens
camarades et devrait passer un très bon
moment
au-delà de cet aspect réhabilitation
cet espace réduit et se veut vitrine des
savoir-faire du conseil général comme
avec l'atelier bois de goyavier ou la
bibliothèque départementale
c'est aussi un lieu de partage et des
changes ou les associations peuvent
venir s'exprimer ou des animations
seront proposées à la population un lieu
de vie ansa
le projet bas de la rivière s'inscrit
dans le projet éco village que le
conseil général veut porter à la réunion
pour montrer qu'il y a une identité
réunionnaise et en même temps un lien
avec la population pour faire vivre et
allié avec les associations pour faire
vivre autrement un quartier il ya eu il
ya les anciens et puis ceux qui vont au
collège
aujourd'hui il ya ce que nous dépendons
sur l'environnement il vit à ce que nous
défendons également sur eux les lieux
d'accueil de la petite enfance des lieux
où les parents peuvent promener de
manière sécurisée des enfants s'amuser
avec eux la bibliothèque départementale
par exemple lieu de création
c'est un projet structurant que nous
voulons pareil m à l'échelle de saint
denis mais aussi à l'échelle de la
réunion parce que c'est ce que nous
voulons préserver dans l'identité que
nous construisons avec la population
donc c'est à l'éco village est un beau
projet plutôt que de construire
seulement et encore des immeubles dans
un lieu campement urbanisées nous avons
préféré l'ouvrir à la population est en
lien avec ceux qui avaient occupé cet
espace à l'image de l'espace redley le
conseil général continue de créer
d'innover de faire perpétuer ces
symboles qui font la réunion
le développement économique est
importante pour la
les réunionnais mais il ne peut être
durable qu'en préservant les valeurs et
l'histoire réunionnaise préserver des
endroits comme l'ancien collège régler
c'est préserver la mémoire de la réunion
et construire la réunion dès demain le
conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais